good evening welcome to Tucker Carlson
tonight what happens when you could no
longer denounce your political opponents
as Russian spies this is a major problem
the Democratic Party right now but they
have a solution you just call them white
nationalists instead it's every bit as
stupid and slanderous and it's even more
effective in shutting them up but what
does it do to the country when you whip
up hatred and fear like that will tell
you just ahead but first tonight the
Attorney General William bar has finally
confirmed what has been obvious for
months now the Obama administration
spied on Donald Trump's presidential
campaign nothing like this has happened
in modern American history Bart dropped
the news almost in passing during
testimony before Congress this morning I
think spying on a political campaign is
a big deal it's a big deal so you're not
you're not suggesting though that spine
occurred I don't well I guess you could
I think there was a spying did occur yes
I think spying did occur I'm not
suggesting it wasn't adequately
predicated but I need to explore that
well there's no disputing the points
that bar made especially the first one
spying on a presidential campaign is a
big deal especially one was authorized
by a rival administration just imagine
if a year from now the Trump
administration allowed the FBI to
surveil officials in the camallo Harris
for president campaign imagine if when
caught Trump pointed to opposition
research generated by the Republican
National Committee as justification for
that surveillance how do me to react to
that story
well like it was a major jaw-dropping
scandal and this show would heartily
agree with that we would not defend that
law enforcement should never be used as
a partisan political tool no matter who
it benefits but the media don't feel
that way about Obama spying they refused
to admit it even was spying professional
dumb person Jennifer Rubin of the
Washington Post attacked the Attorney
General for daring to bring up the topic
at all she called Bar Trump's toady CNN
meanwhile assured its viewers that there
is little evidence that spying occurred
but that's a lie
there is plenty of evidence
that spying occurred and we've had it
for months in 2016 and 17 the FBI
wiretapped Paul Manafort Trump's former
campaign chairman former Trump aide
Carter Paige was spied on extensively by
the US government even though it was
obvious from the very first day that he
was not a Russian spy please
last year we learned that the FBI used
an informant to feed it information from
inside the Trump campaign this is all
spying there's no other word for it
when Trump complained about being spied
on Democrats and their employees in the
media called him a nutcase and a liar
there is no evidence to support any
allegation that the FBI or any
intelligence agency placed a spy in the
Trump campaign is baseless claims of
spies its so-called spy issue first of
all there's absolutely no evidence there
was a spy so it's really a fake issue
this phony baloneys story about a spy on
the campaign to call them a conspiracy
theory is to give them too much credit
just fake facts other people who've seen
the intelligence in your own party are
saying it there's just no there there
I'm wondering what it will take for you
congressman Zeldin say he's full of it
he's crazy it's a conspiracy theory a
lot of Republicans said that too by the
way and we should remember their names
and as it turns out there was in fact a
conspiracy afoot to hide the truth but
Trump was not leading that conspiracy
Jim clapper was was the FBI spying on
Trump's campaign no they were not they
were spying on a term I don't
particularly like but on what the
Russians were doing trying to understand
were the Russians infiltrating trying to
gain access trying to gain leverage and
influence what they do so why doesn't he
like that he should be happy that we
should be it should be got that the
Obama administration wasn't spying
they were just watching him without his
knowledge on behalf of the opposing
party in the closing months of a bitter
presidential campaign no big deal
Trump want to be grateful for that the
Obama people cared enough to surveil his
staff they're patriotic that way they're
big hearted people come on
there's got to be a limit to how much
lying a country can take from its
leaders before things start to fall
apart and we've definitely reached our
limit rush inclusion did not happen
domestic spying during a presidential
campaign did happen and we've a right to
know who participated in it who
authorized it and what their motives
were we've read to know that immediately
right now without redactions this
country does not belong to retired Obama
staffers and Intel agency heads and
mindless CNN contributors Renaud gravely
as they say something you don't
understand
no it's our country this is a democracy
and we ought to act like it's a
democracy